and finally new role psychologists have
to explain how in the age of me to the
number one movie in America is about a
woman on a leash or how in romantic
comedies there are only three plots she
married her boss stalking is romantic
and I hate you and then I love you
[Music]
now it's true that men made most of
these movies but women bought most of
the tickets hi sure wasn't the one who
wanted to go see failure to launch and
fifty Shades of Grey written directed
and devoured by women because people are
complicated that's why there's a
Facebook category it's complicated
we don't know why we're attracted to a
woman or a man or if you've seen shape
of water a fish sometimes people at work
fall in love sometimes people try
something new in bed without having a
pre-production meeting about it not
every guy who makes a woman
uncomfortable did it because he's an
[ __ ] 2017 was a great year for women
because finally men have been put on
notice harassment is going to be noted
now so you're going to have to think of
another way to meet women all men are
playing with five fouls now as they
should but the movement falters if it
thinks we can make pain free the messy
transition from two people not in a
relationship to two people who are a
Harris Poll says 38% of Americans have
dated a co-worker and 31% of office
romances have led to marriage the rest
ended happily
[Applause]
and yet Facebook and Google have
policies where you can only ask a
co-worker out once if she or he says no
you cannot ask again right because
feelings in humans never change
we're rocks [ __ ] women like these
rom-coms precisely because the men don't
change Christian gray starts out as a
sadist and by the end he's traded in his
butt plug for a heated toilet seat Love
Actually is somehow a lot of people's
favorite movie but who was made today it
would have to be called inappropriate
actually it's nothing but men hitting on
their underlings and one character is
such a stalker he shows up at the door
of his married crush who winds up
chasing him down the street and kissing
him most women I know called the police
if you leave a note on their car I'm not
saying men act the way they do primarily
because of movies but they have been
getting this message for a long time
that this is what women want and it is
what women want but only from the men
they want it from problem is we don't
know which one we are you know when Tom
Cruise barges uninvited into the home of
the assistant he's hired and had sex
with and says I'm not letting a get rid
of me how about that adorable
if it was Ted Cruz not so much
Snow White is the tenth highest-grossing
film ever it's about a prince who kisses
Snow White when she's out cold
cute from a prince from Bill Cosby not
cute at all
John Cusack always cute am i right
ladies always kids always cute even when
he shows up outside his ex's house
playing the music they used to have sex
too
in real life the cops arrived mistake
the boombox for a gun and shoot him 57
times who's more beloved than rocky but
his first date moves wouldn't go over
too well at the meet - Film Festival
don't go please not very PC but Rocky
was determined not to spend another
lonely night beating his me
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I also wouldn't try the chair
through the window move used by William
Hurt in body heat but it worked for them
and this isn't just in our unroll cast
it's this year's Oscar nominees Beauty
and the Beast is about a simple country
girl who's kidnapped but it turns out as
a prince so it's okay if you think
there's a power imbalance when the
conductor dates the cellist imagine
being hit on by a hulking dog monster
phantom threat is about a powerful older
man who picks up a waitress call me by
your name is about a 24 year old who has
a gay affair with a 17 year old and the
shape of water is about a cleaning woman
a secret government lab who takes the
Creature from the Black Lagoon home and
bangs it in the bathtub
if that's not workplace sex it's
certainly stealing office supplies